it's becoming the question asked over
and over how can people and their
personal data be protected online an
overhaul of data protection rules are
date back to ninety nine to five aim to
give back power to the people but will
they over to German MEP and Philip L
briefed how can we protect ourselves
from identity theft the bestest to
really decide where you want to put your
personal data and we are not and to
choose services which are more secure
than others how can the EU protect its
citizens information from giant
corporation I think most important is
that the European Union creates a law
which is applicable everywhere on the
European market and gives the consumer
the clear right to determine on its own
which risk he or she wants to take in
the internet or somewhere else on his
personal data or her personal data
sixty-four percent of Europeans fear
their data is not safe in the hands of
public authorities how does the EU
intend to tackle this issue the new EU
data protection regulation should not
only be applicable to private companies
but will also take a public authorities
so also authorities who get my data I
have to respect the individual rights
that I'm informed that i can delete the
data and so on but of course it's still
the question what's proportionate on
surveillance and that's not to be
regulated in their data protection
regulation why should every country
lobby in solitude why not do it together
we need a common approach by the
European market it's the biggest common
market in the world and therefore we
have an effect also on big internet
companies like Facebook Amazon or Google
who need to respect our rights also as
Europeans
I it seems to be careful